I've made plenty of videos discussing
the insane amount of physical training
that song would have to engage in to
perform Batman's feats in real life but
while his ridiculous bench-pressing and
endless endurance are impressive perhaps
what's even more over-the-top in the
comics is his sheer range of skills
Batman is proficient in everything from
lock picking to driving to gymnastics to
engineering to martial arts according to
some continuity he's supposed to know
every single martial art in the world by
the way it's these skills more than his
physical prowess that allow him to take
on far more powerful foes and even go
toe-to-toe with gods and aliens of
course Batman is a fictional character
but many of us would love to be able to
draw from a huge range of different
skills as a situation demanded and to be
genuinely prepared for anything as a
result as someone who wants to improve
his martial arts learn to flip a Qi full
planche increase jump height and more i
likewise need any help I can get in
order to accelerate my skill acquisition
here I'm going to discuss some powerful
strategies for mastering new skills
quickly just like Batman
[Music]
first though the basics of skill
acquisition essentially learning a
physical skill means forming and
strengthening the requisite neural
pathways in the brain when we first
begin learning a new skill we must
consciously consider every aspect of our
posture and movement probably working
from some kind of reference this results
in awkward stilted performance but each
small success results in a slight
dopamine hit which strengthens the
affective neural pathways of practice
over time this allows us to perform more
and more of the movement entirely
unconsciously and intuitively which
increases efficiency in reaction times
various psychological models attempt to
explain this process such as the Dreyfus
model which describes the difference
between the highly conscious and
rule-oriented novice and the intuitive
and reactive expert another popular
model used by sports psychologists even
today is the process of learning motor
skills postulated by P Fitz and M Posner
in 1967 this describes three distinct
phases cognitive associative and
autonomous either way though the point
is that you must first learn the
movement then refine it until it becomes
second nature so one way we're going to
help this process along is something
called spaced learning space learning
essentially means that you're dividing
your learning into smaller blocks so
instead of sitting down to learn
something for an hour you instead break
that session into two 30-minute blocks
or four 15-minute ones usually this is
employed when learning factual
information where it's been shown
through significantly improve retention
the most popular protocol involves
repeating the same content three times
but with two ten-minute breaks in
between it's thought that this works by
allowing the memories to move from
short-term into long-term memory stores
thereby ensuring that you're actually
training your ability to recall that
information and strengthening your
access to it there's also the simple
fact that space learning provides a
break allowing you to resume your
learning feeling fresher later on as
opposed to seeing your results trail off
due to diminishing returns over time
what's really cool though is that this
approach also seems to work for motor
skill acquisition in one study
researchers attempted to train postal
workers on a new typing task they
divided participants into groups using
various different learning schedules it
was found that the spaced learning
groups learned the new tasks faster and
achieved lower error rates and this was
true even when they studied for less
total time in other words it could
theoretically also help you to improve
your punch technique or masters of a
planche more quickly if you're going to
be practicing planche progressions
part of a larger workout then it
actually seems to make sense to break up
that training into blocks but it could
just mean that you use your skill
practice at the start and at the end of
the workout then of course you'll be
more fatigued towards the end this also
makes the case for splitting training
into multiple blocks throughout the day
rather than doing all things in one go
this is something I've been
experimenting with heavily lately with
great results I'll discuss that more on
a post very soon this could even benefit
strength gains by allowing a quicker
neural adaptation of course recovery and
overtraining should be managed carefully
if practicing skills and small blocks
throughout the day sounds familiar it's
probably because you've heard of
greasing the groove greasing the groove
simply means treating strength
performance like skills you herse over
and over any opportunity without
allowing yourself to become fatigued the
classic example is that in order to
become amazing at pull-ups you should
install a pull-up bar on your door and
then do five or six every time you pass
through it the aim is not to fatigue
yourself but to gain the necessary
muscle memory every time you engage in
practice you light up those neural
networks improving your efficiency for
inter muscular coordination and muscle
fiber recruitment greasing the groove
was initially advocated by pavel chat
zulan he recommends that the volume per
session should be small and the
intensity light your practicing not
training stick between fifty to sixty
percent of your maximum effort
as a good benchmark this can be applied
to pretty much anything I've used it
with great success to improve my strict
handstand you can also use it to improve
your max jump height your punching
techniques your golf swing your mobility
or pretty much anything else if it's the
neural networks were focused on though
then perhaps you don't need the physical
movement at all simply visualizing
movement and awesome choreography can
actually trigger almost the precise same
brain activity as though you are
rehearsing it in real life you can
therefore use mental practice as a way
to further enhance greasing the groove
and spaced learning without placing more
stress on the body this makes a lot of
sense for someone like Batman who is
probably severely over trained as it is
believe it or not even watching people
perform the moves you're trying to learn
may be effective in a similar manner and
speaking of overtraining that brings us
to sleep which is an absolutely crucial
piece of the puzzle during sleep our
brain riri hearses the skills we've
practiced during the day it curls
unwanted connections and it moves data
into long-term
memory countless studies support the
notion that sleep is crucial for
procedural memory formation and
strengthening this is why more and more
athletes that focused on getting huge
amounts of sleep see the book why we
sleep by Matthew Walker of course this
is something that Batman would struggle
with due to his rather busy schedule and
I'm in a similar situation because I've
got a young daughter that makes me like
Batman right the best he could hope for
would be to maximize the quality of the
sleep he got possibly using methods to
increase sleep spindles in the necessary
brain regions the number of these high
frequency oscillations appears to
correlate with a rapid skill acquisition
and activity in the motor cortex
apparently if we create an association
between a sound and our skill practice
during the day and then play that sound
during the night we can actually
encourage more activation and spindles
in the relevant region check out the TED
talk from penny Lewis for more on this
if you're a regular viewer then you
might know that I've been experimenting
with a neuro priming device called the
halo sport - this is a transcranial
direct current stimulation device that
works by running a very low current
through the motor cortex thereby
increasing the resting potential of that
region this theoretically helps to
increase activity in that area
potentially improving proprioceptive
muscle fiber recruitment and efficiency
in movement more to the point though it
could also help to put the brain into a
super plastic state to thereby help us
cement those new skills much more
quickly transcranial direct current
stimulation is supported by a lot of
research though the product itself is
still relatively new tDCS is also
considered safe with no studies finding
any negative health effects but keep in
mind that there is a lack of
longitudinal long-term research at this
point reportedly it has been adopted by
athletes and MMA fighters to positive
results but I'm still in the process of
forming my own opinions on it you can be
sure to find a full review soon either
on the YouTube channel or on my website
still this is a pretty Batman s concept
when it comes to enhanced learning and
I'm sure he'd used something like it for
a go let's just share some final tips
for rapid skill acquisition first don't
get disheartened if you hit plateaus
this is actually a normal part of the
learning process but your brain needs to
consolidate existing networks before
forming new important connections you
need to perfect the stage your app
before you can move on to the next
consider super maximal training how do
you practice something you can't do at
all the answer is to find ways to help
yourself into that movement pattern
in order to begin to form those new
necessary neural pathways for instance
you can use momentum to swing up into a
planche try slowing the movement right
down especially using quasi isometrics
during the cognitive phase this will
help to become conscious of everything
your body is doing during the subsequent
stages this can help you to look out for
sticking points poor technique etc try
throwing a super slow punch it's
interesting train for the traits as well
as the skills if you want to learn to
handstand for instance you need to
shoulder mobility core strength shoulder
strength prefer ception and more these
things can be trained separately and
they'll greatly shorten your time to
master the skill and keep learning the
more you learn the more BDNF and
dopamine your brain produces increasing
plasticity theoretically learning a new
skill could even help you to progress
faster with your regular lifts by
helping you to gain more neural Drive of
course you probably are not Batman
therefore you likely don't need to be an
expert stunt driver and to know every
martial art but if you apply these
strategies then you may be able to
progress more quickly than you think in
more areas than you imagined and I'd
love to know any strategies you've used
in the comments down below if you like
this kind of training then check out the
link in the description down below to
find my ebook and training program super
functional training down there you'll
also find a link to the written article
version of this post where I include all
references etc a huge shout out and
thanks to all my patrons who helped me
over at patreon calm if you'd like to
learn more about that then that link is
also down there it really does make a
huge difference
hit subscribe if you want more like this
or take a look around the blog and of
course I'll see you next time thanks a
ton for watching and bye for now